name is Dara sedarian and I'm the studio
product director at Rocksteady Studios
Suicide Squad killed the Justice League
is the next installment in the Arkham
verse and will be releasing this may
it is a third person action shooter set
five years after the events of Batman
Arkham Knight
Metropolis has been invaded and you're
going in as The Suicide Squad members
Harley Quinn King sharp Deadshot and
Captain Boomerang to face off against
the ultimate threat a corrupted Justice
League
the team has been hard at work at
creating the best possible game
experience for our players and we're
very excited to share more as part of
this state of play today let's take a
brief look at one of the missions in our
game The Flash has been corrupted by
Brainiac and as The Suicide Squad you'll
need to work together in up to four
player online co-op to stop the Flash
and rescue Lex Luthor in the process
enjoy
let's [__] something up
oh you know what
hold on a sec hello Brainiac
is it happening now
great you will have Luther ASAP
you want Luther all you have to to do is
come and get him
what the hell was that flash just alive
and he has Luther one damn thing at a
time
that artillery is going to wreak havoc
on our front line if there's a
snowball's chance in hell you can
destroy it I expect you to no matter the
cost are we clear
yeah
where the snowball
time to light them all up
on my way
all my big eyes Let's Dance
oh
that's gonna leave a mark
yeah focus on firing on this tank why do
we never get reinforcements
[Music]
love explosions
thank you
incoming
Roger that Quinn
I've come we got more company go start
go
senseless violence
kill that weak spot Squad no worries
[Music]
just call me the Pinball Wizard
Unstoppable
thank you
this one won't die already
[Music]
Rising like a wave
ouch I love our escapades
thank you
though how the whole taking down the
flash thing go
still in play let me get out of my way I
have work to do
well hey there sleepyhead we've got an
interrogation to get back to
foreign
you think I'm just gonna let you walk
away
until these guys everything you know
you think they can stop us
pathetic pathetic
at least I'm not a big hero turn stooge
for a space man
okay boomerang
you want to see what a real hero can do
I'll show you
oh no
blush how do I stop this
please tell me how
careless Diana
we have to die
save the world
Suicide Squad killed the Justice League
arrives on PS5 May 26th
Rocksteady Studios has even more to
share today let's listen in
show me what you got
Suicide Squad kill Justice League is an
extension of the Arkham verse and it's
really about now reframing the story and
telling it from the villain's point of
view where are we going and who are we
killing it's a mixture of lots of the
things I hope the fans like about
Rocksteady but like a whole massive
chunk of new stuff that they've never
seen before
we've always seen Batman's perspective
on this world and we thought it'd be
really fun and enjoyable to see this
universe but Through The Eyes of the
villains
Story five years after the end of Arkham
Knight and A lot's changed in that time
just checking we're all seeing that
thing right Brainiac has invaded Earth
and he's this huge threat overlooking
Metropolis he's taken over Metropolis
City the Justice League are there to try
and save the city but Brainiac has
captured and brainwashed them and turned
them against the very people they've
been sworn to protect oh [__]
Superman
so the Justice League share the same
goal as a brainiac to take over Earth
and turn it into the nucleus what we've
created is a classic Justice League but
with the sense that there's something
wrong with them they are now doing
brainiac's bidding and Amanda Waller
scrambles to try to remedy this and
essentially save the Earth and she
recruits for lovable characters into
fighting the Justice League in an effort
to reclaim the Earth and thwartz
brainiac's plans your new mission is to
kill the Justice League the members of
The Suicide Squad are Harley Quinn
Captain Boomerang Deadshot and king
shark Harley Quinn is definitely the
most acrobatic of the cruise she's
always moving she's always flying
through the air in her barely controlled
ways the feeling of swinging and the
momentum and the kind of physicality of
it and trying to keep that momentum
going and use that to go over buildings
or swing under bridges and China into
kind of the grapple mechanic that she's
got it just feels spot on
I'm a freaking
good shot has the iconic Deadshot look
but with a rock steady twist he's got a
real Swagger to him and in this game we
can also hover with his jet pack in
super precise he uses sniper rifles
assault rifles and pistols and they all
fit with his sort of the fantasy of
playing as Deadshot as this master
assassin but you want team waller or
team get the hell out of this mess king
shark to me as as a person is well as a
fish is this incredible character who's
super well read and super well to do and
I'm sure could smash an operatic
performance actually I'm the son of a
god
as much shame to suffer Mortals in their
buffoonery but also doesn't really know
simple words or simple things that are
going on I think that's brilliant in
terms of combat he is a brute he's a
tank character he can take more damage
his abilities will lean into the fact
that he wants to get in a bit more close
and personal he's the fastest Melee
character
Captain boomerang's got his speed force
Gauntlet that he can use together with
his boomerang he can throw it to any
point in space and speed force to that
point along the walls along the floor
and get wherever he wants to go you can
use that get up close Dodge around in
midair taking out the enemies and then
scarper because he doesn't want to stick
around don't worry guys I'm here one of
the most exciting parts that connects
our game to the DC lore are the support
Squad he's off Widow and you have
penguin the arm stealer you're making
guns for us now bird brain but also some
new faces pack who is a digital ghost
that is helping the squad both navigate
the world but also upgrade their neck
bombs that's a big adrenaline Spike you
on a nice bomb sending out this toy man
who's helping the squad with perfecting
gear
and then finally we have Gizmo who is
helping the squad with insane vehicle
Creations that let you blow [__] up
Metropolis is your playground you're
going to get to meet different
characters different villains and you
really get to see these cool iconic
locations being the city of Tomorrow
kind of like meant stark contrast with
good MCT which is very dirty it's always
raining and that contrasts with like a
city that's very Grand it's very clean
it's very functional the huge difference
between metropolis and Gotham is that
Metropolis really acknowledge and really
trust Superman so there is a lot of
statues to thank Superman for everything
he's done for the city you're getting to
see Metropolis through the villain's
eyes you're going to experience this
world and Traverse view this world as
the villains
Metropolis to the core ability of
everything wraps around in Suicide Squad
is your traversal how that works with
combat is you're chaining your combat
moves together with those reversal moves
and the combat encounters are all
designed to push and pull you around the
environment in a battlefield that's
constantly changing working out how to
use all your different weapons your guns
your melee attacks and how to use them
all to your best advantage to control
the chaos and come out Victorious what's
awesome about Gunplay is the variety so
there's six core types of weapon
families we've got assault rifles SMGs
sniper rifles shotguns miniguns and
pistols there's added variety from
weapon manufacturers there's lexcorp
weapons there's gcp weapons there's
armor attack weapons later on in the
game we also have gear sets the gear
sets are villain themed for example if
you have a bane gear set and you trigger
his Buffs in the game some of it will
have the beam drums and you will like
burn and like boom boom boom and then
there's like green smoke and you trigger
all kind of effects so you're basically
taking the essence of the villain you're
bringing it into the game
each character has a power level in the
game that we call gear score as you
acquire new gear in the game your gear
score goes up and as that number goes up
it means that you can take how much
harder missions as part of this
progression Journey you will unlock more
and more bills more and more ways to
customize your character to really fit
the way you want to play every firearm
in our game is upgradable so in Suicide
Squad killer just it's like you're gonna
get lots of choice to use the weapons
that you need and to complete your
missions but most importantly you will
be able to customize your squad to be
whatever you like you can wear whatever
you want any of the outfits you can be
running around in your Asylum jail
outfit and still have like the best gear
score ever I like it our game is a one
to four player co-op experience which
means that all the missions in the game
have been designed to support solo play
playing with a friend two friends or
three friends for the single player fans
you can play in single player with Bots
filling in the role of the squad so you
still feel like you're part of a team
and you can switch them if you want and
try king shark now or we can say well I
think Harley will be a better fit for
this Mission so I'm going to switch over
and try her out but if you really want
to tear it up going in with a full group
of four lets you experience the full
Mayhem the suicide squad has to offer
and you get to really experience the
Dynamics between how you can all play
together in different play Styles in
order to take on Brainiac and the
Justice League
all the fun is right here when the
story's done your experience doesn't end
there Rocksteady will continue its
Legacy of supporting the game after it's
launched we're going to deliver lots of
new content to our players we're going
to have new playable characters new
weapons and New Missions for players who
like to customize their looks we'll
offer a battle pass that only contains
cosmetic items there's just gonna be so
much for the players to enjoy just
picture it Harley Quinn kills the
Justice League if you like story games
if you like RPG elements if you like
co-op games if you like customizing your
characters if you want to play as a
badass this game kind of has it all it's
very fast paced it's really colorful
it's loud and Unapologetic and in your
face and it's going to be really really
fun hey Macho
like live executions well don't touch
that dial or I'll break your fingers